all right the garyvee audio experience
brings you after the app and this is the
important show because these two
gentlemen are the generals they are the
infrastructure the backbone the
captain's a planet of the apps Ben
Silverman Howard Owens I am humbled to
have you on the podcast for the couple
of people in the vaynernation
that don't know who you gentlemen are
how are we going to start with you and
your beautiful face tell everybody who
you are and a little bit about your
career I'm Howard Owens great to see a
Gary Vee great to talk to
banner nation love you guys big fans
first time first time caller longtime
listener I you're not calling you're
actually against I know but I'm just
referring to talk radio eternal Jesus
Christ you're ruining the show each
second into this I turned my ringer off
yeah I said let's listen how would you
remove over there after a right birth
Howard yes no I'm we're gonna go with
you while Howard drinks a little water
here and tries to reset himself Televi
no nation who you are you've an amazing
career I mean if people go into this
Google hole they'll be there for five
days you're such a young man you've got
such a prolific career in the Hollywood
landscape and I'm so tell everybody who
you are on planner the apps and a little
bit about your career EP an executive
producer of plan of the apps with my
partner over here Howard T Owens the
third the son of a Connecticut
legislature and judge so helped I'll
help do Howard Howard's job here thank
you
a man of the nation from Bridgeport and
not the good part of town okay we all
know Bridgeport got two sides other side
of the truck other side of the track
self-made self-made man but have been a
serial entrepreneur and executive in the
entertainment world creating TV shows
producing TV shows traveling the world
looking for great ideas things like
doing the Virgin Ugly Betty the office
that I feed executive-produced
and and then many other shows co-created
Biggest Loser with Howard and some
colleagues Nashville star date my mom
the restaurant tons of different genres
of TV had the great privilege of you
know rehiring Donald Trump
the Celebrity Apprentice when I was
chairman of NBC and Universal Media and
have been enjoying making content
forever and love plan of the apps just
feels like a game-changing show I had a
show a long time ago called Fashion Star
yes where we had Saks Fifth Avenue hmm
and Macy's as my judges on the show but
basically investing there go to buy
product live think a little bit Project
Runway meets HSN almost and and that was
kind of something that was in my head
when Howard approached me about plan of
the apps and that he was thinking about
the app space and collaborate it's
interesting about that show I think I
got to tell you this while we were
filming that show more than any show as
me living my life blew my mind when I
hurt when I knew that there was business
dynamics to the content Jessica Simpson
right exactly I remember that call
Richie junker but I remember this
clearly I was like holy [ __ ] it was the
a packer it was at two thousand four
five six seven like we're at seven eight
yeah I just remember it was like reality
was really happening and I just remember
thinking you know that was such a big
business if it was a humongously hit
show obviously you've had a lot of hits
that show didn't go crazy the way I
thought it was going to probably not the
way you guys thought it was going to as
well but the business model was bonkers
bonkers and with apps we thought what
what was incredible is you could that
night download yes you can actually
write within the content ecosystem you
back called--or back now and buy the app
you know or get the app or experienced
yep and i think ben's what Ben did with
Fashion Star and prior to that what we
did with Biggest Loser which was offer
you know weight loss programs and diets
to the audience who were fans of loser
you know Ben took at the next level then
with fashion star and I what we saw with
Planet of the apps' foot was that the
whole and in doing with Apple is the
whole ecosystem of consumption of media
following your own apps becoming part of
the show and being able to experience
and purchase or download and you know
that that whole 360 is ever existed
before when
we were working on this and I think we
talked to you Gary B about this early on
it's as you know if Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire democratised the game show
that's this finger you could literally
play the game from home and be on the
show what people forget it during that
initial cycle of millionaire which aired
on ABC aired initially five days in a
row than five member in a row aired for
ten it was crazy
ten nights in the room we had the
privilege of putting that show together
and bring it over to America rihanna's
dominated dominate he was our first
choice Dom wasn't me the second choice
somebody tell me you wanted you told me
a good story he wasn't a second choice
but we thought about Donahue yes I love
that because I want to be down here I
don't know I think I'm gonna bring
Donahue back in Gary Vee form I'm doing
daytime TV I think and I want people to
call me ingredien Iowa what do you say
like I've been dreaming about this by
the way you were manifesting all your
other dreams why won't you be the next
Donahue and then I'm going to win seven
Super Bowls is the owner of the New York
Jets and then I'll be ready to go I
think the ladders a lot tougher for I
think I might you know I'm more on the
Bitcoin and the I get the druze I don't
know I was thinking more Dinoco or very
good what's that hot Michael Douglas
Michael Douglas yeah oh you've got us
but but so if millionaire democratize
the game show yeah one of those early
episodes you saw a guy whose partner was
in the Arctic first time you had a gay
contestant yeah it just happened as the
guy was smart and he won the fastest
finger and got his way out of the show
wasn't cast in the normal way then you
looked at what Idol did you voted with
your phone well you made the choice it
actually started a Big Brother there was
a whole lawsuit in your family but my
brother did that telephony first that
wasn't it you know the name for around
using your phone to vote and around
everything with the phone at that time
now apps is one step further where
you're literally voting with your click
and your desire to download download
this this app and participate in that
way and then obviously the shows
emotional heart is these extraordinary
American Dreams these amazing men and
women from all over the place you know
which I loved as well about the show
because it's democratized
entrepreneurship technology has enabled
people like you Gary panacek to be a
king yep and you
that's a lot harder than when you would
have started trying to become and
compete I 185 year we were talking last
night about the casting process just
talking to Nikki last night and we were
talking about casting and finding apps
and how we went and did it
and people are and you yourself said
people have reached out to you since
your shows come on and you're like oh my
god they want to have their app on the
show it's a great experience part of the
idea behind the show is not different
from say Nashville star where the first
season we found Miranda Lambert yep who
was a 18 year old singer songwriter
guitar player who Sony Music told us
you'll never really find anyone this is
for posterity it'll be good for
marketing for the for the brand we find
Miranda Lambert in this show one of the
things that we think is cool and helpful
is to allow the glass ceiling of Silicon
Valley to be shattered is allow anyone
with an idea in that you know kind of
perseverance to come and wait in line
and make their video and pitch their
wares but we as you know Gary and Aaron
here still with us we go through an
extremely you know rigid vetting process
where we really want to make sure what
was people have what it takes but the
fact that anyone can do it we don't
really know who you are we don't check
your CV before you come on the show is
what is what great opportunity but even
greater is that's the micro of the macro
which is this show is bringing awareness
to that world but there's millions of
people that will never be on this show
that are just doing a direct-to-consumer
at scale you guys are reacting to the
reality this is a synthesized version
that gives you even great exposure to
the genre but this is happening every
day right now people are listening
they'll never be casted on the show
because they're still that gatekeeper
aspect and things of that nature and
that is the most powerful thing because
as we continue to bring awareness to
what's actually going on it inspires
those that may not go through this
funnel that just might make a great
product and put on the App Store and
that's a big deal I think I think it's
been the age of the grinder now it's the
age of the hustler and I need to find a
new canteen a grinder a hustler a
hustler works just as hard as a grinder
but they know that the know is
irresistible and they're going to come
on top they're not going to like work
half yes into the know they're going to
take that no and make it a yes Holland
and that and the hustler also is living
in this age of maybe I'm going to skip
my education the old fast right maybe
I'm not going to build a retail outlet
maybe I'm not going to spend my money on
marketing maybe I'm going to use a
different kind of currency maybe I'm
going to bet on myself maybe I'm going
to go to the bank and get a line of
credit maybe I'm not going to enter this
system this door and I think it's these
people are growing up and using their
their whole street-smart skill along
with their intellect and idea and it's
really different you feel it
oh you're different Howard biggest
surprise from what you thought was going
to go down to what's manifested you know
one of the surprises really and I
shouldn't say it was a surprise because
we wanted to happen but until it happens
you don't see it is you Jessica Gweneth
and will be coming so personally
invested in the apps and the creators
and seeing you guys go to town and
seeing you get on planes and meet these
people and seeing you really you know
care and I think that we we thought that
we cast you guys we think you're awesome
but you're incredibly busy running
empires you have a lot of other things
on your plate but you guys dug deep and
we I was impressed by the ability for
you and your Co partners your advisors
to stay emotionally and mentally
connected to the process which was hard
you know when we did this we shot over
you know 10 13 days and we did 15 hour
days and you guys saw I think over a
hundred apps it's a it's a big process
you put a lot into that you really you
know there's a lot of information coming
at you and so your perseverance and your
guys ability to really help lift this
experience has been awesome then you
know I'm I'm still in it yeah it's
really early yeah for me the moment as
as the culture starts to expand and
absorb it I'm thrilled that we're
starting our consumer-facing marketing
campaign and lighting it up right with
Apple than a network which is gonna do
everything up front and Apple kind of
doing it along the way is that been
intriguing for you mean used to run NBC
like how are you feeling about that I'm
totally into it because it is new and
exciting for me and watching it play out
and knowing where it hits the consumer
knowing when the consumer fine
and whether it's somebody kind of
entering these new doors like whether
it's on the.com through the Apple music
platform or on Apple music itself or on
the Apple TV platform you know all of
these different touch points inside
iTunes and then through to Apple music
is really cool and the global we haven't
yet pointed our megaphone globally Apple
has turned on its platform globally but
we haven't yet gone into the rest of the
world which we're going to start to do
and that it's going to be really cool
too as we watch and find how much the
Ukrainians love garyvee of course I mean
quarter save you and as I mean I was
born in Belarus people and Ben you
mentioned something to me which i think
is totally true and I we may have said
this to Gary but one of the things that
we didn't know you know we wanted the
escalator pitch to work and be a great
experience and we had tested it out and
look good but we couldn't Bank on was
that all the entrepreneurs and all the
app creators are video creators in
general talk about the hustler the
grinder these people these you know
whether from 17 to 70 everyone you know
by creating their app understands
visuals and utters everyone for your
companion up on that screen who's
watched the show and thought oh I get it
that's a great idea and then I have my
aunt Amy up and you know who's an
architect sending me her tweaks and
companion and how to do use it with old
people and the way she went of the
target market and then I move on your
aunt Amy old my aunt Amy is old respect
but she started old declared so yeah I
think one of the things surprises the
escalator pitch you know defined for up
me it's like the age of the storyteller
anyone coming down in 60 seconds can
tell a wrenching story something really
important because they live it and
they're used to selling it that's how
their and all the facts themselves are
manifested in the screen enabled world
and that segue in the moment in the show
when you throw from what they're doing
on their iPad or on their phone to the
actual screen in the in the studio was
like an aha this is a new lexicon of Arc
Howard without using names obviously
will was very involved very very early
he was locked in as one of the mentors
without naming names you got three other
mentors how many names were considered
for those three spots and how did you
guys do with your priority unless I'm
sure you know you went through a lot of
names before you got down to me so I
died but not a short list I have to tell
you what was the last I am in fighting
us we're trying some scoops on your on
around the audio DB really got our first
choices
period yeah here it just will be that we
did held out the log on it
we didn't say let's go at somebody like
Gwyneth Paltrow and then go get somebody
just like tangential we didn't go like
Jessica you guys are really into this
studio and disrespecting me in the face
and telling me the for Nate I mean
there's no way I was a user hello Greg
Vander blue I mean it's called real yeah
Gary Vee yes you came with the tornado
of enthusiasm supporting you not just
from you in the moment your name
surfaced the army turned on its its
megaphone and that army is also of all
of the incredible friends and
entrepreneurs that you supported a work
with or people you've given advice to
and it just started like machine-gun
fire on us and Jimmy Iovine our kind of
mentor and join Godfather here and the
epic Apple musics Maino built built this
you know that is incredible
he really connected to you immediately
know that about 30 20 second come on
that knowledge yes that Nilan know that
he is it's Brotherhood and and we were
and truthfully Ling and Howard were
absolutely really do I mean all I was
try to be a business you I was it not
you I'm very aware to reach out to you
thinking I'm like he wants to bank the
show he wants to finance it he doesn't
want because actually you wanted if I
wanted to be the singular VC
yeah you wanted to be the main see and
the MIT show it was a whole I want to be
the mentor the people pitching and the
behavior should been planning around
what everyone should and I end up now
now let's talk about some inside scoops
first day of filming was November 14th
my birthday I refused to not be with my
family
so I missed it you guys did some run
throughs Howard I think you
you sat in for me and acted as me that's
true it was a disaster I come the net we
were all pet the greatest of all time do
we then give me the credit for being the
glue of this show I think we more than
confirmed Howard's
ineptitude I'm not sure but but while
you may have salad velvet sand in the
desert yeah we we felt very good that
that show is going to crush and and I
albeit you are a star among stars what
when you turn on that screen in the 4k
and are watching at home all chilled out
in any manifestation you want and you
see the four of you up on that screen
you're not seeing for people like you
that accomplished that focus that
articulate and half of them that
beautiful yeah I mean only can and the
other thing is you have four different
personalities and bring something you
know different do it from a TV
perspective totally but also then what
we saw which is fascinating you all of
this is different business filters
filters in different ways that you
conduct in different ways that you think
and that added another wrinkle to it
that we really hadn't anticipated which
is awesome do you guys get excited as I
do that forever forever you will be
associated with producing Apple musics
first original show I mean just you know
whatever happens if there's a scene to -
if there's 30 seasons it's just always
there and I think it speaks to knowing
your guys career a little bit
it's that innovation arm right you know
we you know fashion stars I mean look I
had no until you brought it up one day
in the trailer I didn't know that was
you guys I didn't know the Hollywood
landscape to me that was just very smart
and for me that's like credit I think in
a lot of ways this new distribution
obviously Netflix and other OTT s exist
but let's call it what it is this is the
most powerful company in the world at
this moment this is their first foray
into something that you guys grew up in
right like you know to me a lot of this
has happened backwards entrepreneurship
and it's backed into culture this is
what you guys dreamed and aspire to do
your whole life must be pretty fantastic
it were psyched it's amazing and I'll
just say that one of the things that has
been really
one of the things that has been such a
great gift is that Apple has really
supported creativity from the beginning
we pitched in the show they liked the
idea and they really allowed us to make
it and they've really kind of there it's
no surprise that great things happen
here and that you know that they've been
responsible for some of the most
innovative things things launches ever
yep and they support creative thinking
well that sign design is such a core
element to the culture of the company
and so we're all kind of designers in
this convergent world whether we're you
know tech entrepreneurs video makers
platform builders there's an element of
design and aesthetic that permeates
everything we're all doing especially as
it relates let's wrap up with this
because there's a lot of people
listening I know my audience what's
happening in Hollywood it's changing
right the games changing we're talking
about OTT influencers how things get
funded it's never been better to be a
great creator because you do have Hulu
Apple music Amazon to go along with HBO
and Showtime to go along with the
network's
Facebook is going to have its original
port like like what is happening in this
town from some real vets right from
forget about the Apple forget about the
battalion and light speed in the Gary
VTech filter what's the Hollywood inside
talk do people realize it's changing do
they think it's good you think it's bad
what's the punchline in this town I
think there's a combo effect going on
and there's definitely a generational
shift and those who love culture
creation and storytelling a pretty
content because they're getting the
stories told and I created those who
just care about Bucks are a little
nervous because the dollar is getting
squeezed by all these giant vertically
integrated companies and this massive
oligopoly that controls voice in America
real and fake voice in America is a
little intimidating for the storytelling
community because it's hard to get your
stories sustained in that environment
and it's a little scary on the business
side and that and that's something that
you feel like this combination of
excitement from those who are here about
you know the pure creativity and
nervousness from those have been in the
game a long time and are watching things
go from 22 episodes to 10 from owning
backends
open markets to owning back ends and
profit participation going into closed
markets there's a lot of nothing that is
nerve-wracking in that sense Howard and
one of the things you guys were talking
about earlier is in the VC world that
coin is the new thing that coin is the
new you know and in our vernacular which
storytellers like Ben and I are saying
is that video is the new currency and in
that we live in a video enabled world my
kids don't you know yes they probably
text and stuff but they live in a you
know on YouTube and on Instagram and
it's a visual video enabled world and I
think as that grows the opportunity for
storytellers just if you don't expands
and Matt replies and word is bullish on
a are V are also where you get to tell
the story Tuesday night's 9et right 9:00
p.m. eastern 9 p.m. Pacific midnight
Eastern oh is that right such a great
launching pad right now that's not even
that was that I think that was the first
episode yeah yeah we're glad like I said
you scared a little Academy yeah mine I
am ET to scare myself I did it came out
of your lips you're like why the [ __ ]
are we launching at midnight on the East
Coast like yeah east coast of south
coast in your today I'm a sailor or
heard like a lays an afterthought
ratings wives likewise but it's good to
you
discounted the rest of the world who
also will get it at varying times I'm in
America listen I might have been born in
the Soviet Union but I'm American
Americans don't even realize Canada or
Mexico I mean Americans are terrible
guests as the man has been a Ghana and
Romania the past ten days yes you do
travel guys yes but I'm trying to speak
for the people you Rock Tyler you thank
God thank you for dying oh you're the
best guy see ya hey guys I hope you
really enjoyed this episode of the Gary
B experience now go out and share this
pass it on let me know what you thought
you